just a lot of very exciting you know AI
features that we you know already
infused into Microsoft products like
office 365 but at the Microsoft we also
want to make sure that we can offer this
kind of incredible AI experiences in the
to our partners and the developers now
how can we help them tributes you know
just as exciting a I applications
I've talked early about AI platforms and
other things I also want to mention that
in a key to making greet a I apps is the
data that's where you know actually
Microsoft using a unique position to
offer our partners developers and the
partners to help them to beaut AI
applications by providing that Microsoft
graphs it includes the word knowledge
graph like what you can get from bing
and the LinkedIn and also work knowledge
graph data from office 365 dynamics now
imagine that you know all our custom our
customers and partners you know they can
combine Microsoft graphs with their own
you know business data and knowledge
about their own users to build
incredible AI applications you know for
their customers for the employees and
for their business so we feel very very
excited about this the opportunities
there that we can work together and the
one particularly unique thing about a
Microsoft is that we have worked long in
the heart to bring many of these graphs
you know together contained within a
compliance boundary that actually
conforms to our privacy compliance and
also data policies that's very very
important to enterprises so those
investments really underscore what we
have been doing you know in Microsoft ai
and the research those are five things
actually I talked to you today I just
want to finish my presentation by
mentioning you know some also importance
and exciting topics nowadays as people
talk about AI developments in
partnership in society and also in
ethics so as we embrace this AI frontier
you know we have to acknowledge that you
know concerns about AI do exist and it's
actually important that we have some
universal design principles and values
that help guide our thinking our design
and development at Microsoft we take in
the ethical approach to AI design
sincerely and seriously our principled
approach is actually very critical you
know we do those things thoughtfully and
the unit Trust was the way posts inside
Microsoft and also outside
for example internally you know we have
organized an advisory committee that
helps ensure the hearings of these
principles in our own AI development and
externally we recognize that we cannot
do that alone
so we co-founded the partnership on AI
just over a year ago this is actually a
nonprofit organization where you see you
know many leading tech companies and
academia civil societies and many many
nonprofit organizations who actually
care about the future of AI development
so this is actually set up to study
formulate and share the best practices
on AI technology for all of us so we
also believe that we need to give back
as we develop AI so I'd like to take
this opportunity to thank I at your list
you know who is a great partner in our
AI for Earth's program they are here
today I encourage you to stop by their
booth to talk to them what they do for
our society and finally I would say as
the first generation to live with AI we
play a very unique role in shape shaping
the future as we will do so you know
that is actually thoughtful that is
really our number one focus in Microsoft
so there's a lot we don't really know
about the AI is impacting yet but what
we do know is that AI has a lot of
potential
to really improve lives and it's already
happening now so let me share a story
with you about how AI has given voices
to those who otherwise would have had
none
SwiftKey symbols is a communication app
for people who are non-verbal and it
supports them in expressing themselves
Roman my youngest brother has low friend
healing autism he finds it difficult to
communicate and can get very upset if he
can't make himself understood
I took what we used at home with some
symbols that my mum would print out
laminate cut out stick velcro and put
them into folders and I just thought I
could make that easier if we did it on
an app so more fun for Rowan because he
loves technology the underlying IO
technology which SwiftKey simples uses
is the same technology which powers a
SwiftKey keyboard or we use a o
technology to be able to learn from the
user's behavior to see what they like to
use in terms of their own style of
language to predict what's going to come
next
it works by having a library of symbols
that you can pick and choose to build
your sentence and each symbol has a word
associated with it and that we used
SwiftKey AI predictive technology to
learn what you've used previously
sentences that you've previously built
and then we surface what word you might
want next and what symbol you might want
next to build your sentence we developed
it alongside Riverside school which is a
school specializing in learning
difficulties to be able to express what
they want without prompting is a really
big thing
we have so many people's who are
non-verbal but still have so much to say
I think I can just make everything in
life more efficient so you can enjoy
life to the max there's no better
feeling than to hear a child say
something that I wanted to say and the
look on their face after they've been
able to say it you can't really beat
that because that's them expressing
themselves and that's really what you
want from them
it's joyous I don't think I can think of
a better word for it it's complete joy
and celebration it's really an
incredible time working on AI and the
use AI to amplify human ingenuity and
we're very excited to work on those
things that a Microsoft thank you very
much again for joining us today
you know please you know if you have
time hang on here check out all the
boozes thank you very much